SPEAKER: Over the
past decade, we've
seen a drastic change in the
types of traffic patterns
that application developers
have to plan for.
One day, you could be at
standard traffic, and the next,
you need to scale to handle
tens of thousands more visitors.
This, of course, leads
to all sorts of issues
with cost, response
times, and scale,
and there's no place
in your application
where this is felt more
than in your database.
Whether it's dealing
with scale or just
struggling to fit unstructured
data into a relational schema
design, most
relational databases
struggle to solve these issues.
This is where
Couchbase comes in.
As a highly scalable,
high-performance,
NoSQL document
database, Couchbase
is one of the fastest
NoSQL databases available,
entirely designed with
modern applications in mind.
And right now, there's nothing
more modern than running
a database using Kubernetes.
See, Kubernetes has rapidly
increased in sophistication
with things like operators,
persistent volumes,
helping developers transition
to the cloud and scale where
they need to.
This is why we've built
a special Kubernetes
operator called the Couchbase
Autonomous Operator.
And it gives you the ability
to deploy multi-node clusters
by writing a small configuration
and pushing it to Kubernetes,
recovering automatically
from node failures,
automatically scaling your
cluster up or down as load
from the application
changes ensuring
that nodes in the cluster
are evenly split across racks
or zones in the data center.
You can also automatically
upgrade the cluster
to a newer version
of Couchbase Server
and manage cluster
configuration to ensure
that the configuration is
properly set in your cluster.
And to help bring this power to
you, without all the headaches,
we've teamed up with
the GCP Marketplace
to make deploying and managing
Couchbase completely automated.
Let's take a quick
look at how easy
it is to set up a
Couchbase cluster on GKE
using the Couchbase Autonomous
Operator through the GCP
Marketplace.
The first thing you need
to do is log into GCP,
then navigate to the
Google Kubernetes Engine.
Then click the Applications
link to get to the Applications
Marketplace.
Click Deploy from the
Marketplace, and then
scroll down to get to the
Couchbase Autonomous Operator.
Click the Configure button
to configure a new operator,
and then make sure that
the operator is going
to be installed into the
correct cluster, in our case,
standard-cluster-1,
and click Deploy.
It'll take a few moments to
actually deploy the operator,
but once it's done, you
should get to a screen that
looks like this.
This means that the Couchbase
operator has been successfully
deployed, and that you
can now move forward
to creating your first
Couchbase cluster.
The next thing
that you need to do
is define a configuration for
your first Couchbase cluster
that you want to create.
In this example, we create
a three-node cluster
with the data, index,
and query service,
one bucket named Default,
and we're running a Couchbase
Enterprise 5.5.2.
Push this configuration to
your Kubernetes cluster,
and the operator
will automatically
start creating a new
Couchbase cluster
based on the specification
that we just defined.
After a few minutes, you should
see that your Couchbase cluster
is created, and you have access
to the Couchbase Administration
console.
If you click on
the Servers button,
you'll see that we have a
three-node cluster created,
and if you click
on the Buckets tab,
you'll see that we
have a default bucket.
Just by running a
few commands, we
can use the Couchbase Operator
to deploy the cluster for us.
If any of our
Couchbase nodes fail,
then the operator will get
the Couchbase cluster back
into a healthy state.
If we need to upgrade the
cluster to a later version
in the future, then we
can have the Operator take
care of the upgrade for us.
We aim to make management of
Couchbase clusters a thing
of the past and envision a
world where users no longer need
to focus on managing
their infrastructure
and can spend all their time
building their applications.
And when it comes to running the
Couchbase Autonomous Operator
on Google's GKE, it just works.
Visit the GCP Marketplace
today to set up
a Couchbase cluster on GKE,
or visit the link below
to learn more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]